really excited to meet our next guest
because she is someone who's been
putting all of her time
and energy into doing some real good in
her community of charlotte north
carolina
she's taken her party planning business
and turned it into a
love and appreciation machine for local
seniors in a campaign that
she calls adopt a grandparent and here
to tell us about it
and by the way gosh it's tiffany moreno
hello tiffany
tiffany adopted grandparent is so smart
please just tell us about the program i
just wanted to do something that was
going to
be for others we've been so fortunate
during kova to stay busy with our bloom
business
and we you know i just decided one day
another balloon
artist inspired me in another part of
the country and i said i think i can do
something like this
and i just came up with my own twist on
it and it
just has taken off well i just love this
and i love what you're doing and i want
to know what it's like there on the
ground when you're there making those
deliveries what kind of reactions do you
get from people
uh well first we mostly only see staff
besides through windows and things like
that and just like
some um outdoor if they're able to come
outside
to receive the balloons but just from
the staff alone when they come
and they get the balloons from us
they are so thankful and so appreciative
i get goosebumps when i think about it
and they
the staff is just so thankful they said
oh
so and so inside was so excited and
they're so surprised that somebody
wanted to do something that
doesn't even know them and just
you can tell that they have been working
so hard to bring smiles to these
seniors faces and just knowing that they
are just
delivering all this joy that we were
able to provide
i mean you just really can't get any
better than that yeah that's it joy
right and you set out a goal of reaching
just
um 50 seniors which seemed like a big
goal at the time
but you've now reached 900.
and now i know but now raising
over 24 000 is that correct
wow i think it was just you know i
wanted to do it where we weren't gonna
make money on it we just wanted to do a
nice thing
and just i think that that amount of
money
knowing you know if you're sitting at
home and you can't volunteer
people still want a chance to give back
they still want to do something
and we just happen to come up with an
idea that is out of the box
and you know that you're providing joy
to people who need it more than anybody
else the loneliest people that there are
right now
are the seniors yeah and they can just
look at those balloons and know
like that balloon said you are loved
they are loved and those cards i think
those cards
have so much it just
really can't do anything that just warms
your heart so much
well thank you tiffany for everything
that you are doing
adopt a grandparent makes so much sense
it's so
amazing okay so go to the drewberrymore
show.com
and let's drive up support
for tiffany's business adopt a
grandparent thank you
so much tiffany truly
you